[Musik]
weitgehendes aus für den soli der
bundestag beschließt eine teil
abschaffung der steuer ab 2021 zu spät
finden viele die masernimpfung wird
pflicht eltern müssen ihre kinder ab
märz impfen lassen verweigern drohen
hohe bußgelder
grünes licht fürs berliner museum der
moderne trotz steigender kosten sicher
der haushaltsausschuss die finanzierung
für das prestige projekt
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg berliner museum der
moderne natürlich entschuldigung dafür
und guten abend zum nachrichtenüberblick
an diesem donnerstag an meiner seite ist
für den sport norbert lehmann junior vor
mir
30 jahre nach dem mauerfall wird der
soli für den aufbau ost abgebaut
allerdings nicht gleich sondern erst
2021 und auch nicht für alle
das hat der bundestag heute beschlossen
der staat wird dadurch im ersten jahr
und 10 milliarden euro weniger einnehmen
dieses geld sparen die steuerzahler
wer und wer nicht zeigt bluten muss 90
prozent zahlen gar keinen soli mehr und
zwar singles mit weniger als 74.000 euro
jahresbrutto und familien mit zwei
kindern bis knapp 152000 6,5 prozent der
steuerpflichtigen zahlen weiter
soli-zuschlag allerdings weniger das
gilt für singles mit maximal 110000 euro
jahresbrutto und familien mit zwei
kindern bis rund 221.000 3,5 prozent die
spitzenverdiener mit den höchsten
einkommen zahlen wie bisher den
kompletten solidaritätszuschlag das
alles gilt ab 2021
allerdings gibt es bedenken gegen das
gesetz der abbau komme zu spät solle
schon ab januar gelten er sei außerdem
ungerecht und verfassungswidrig sagen
die kritiker der opposition im bundestag
aus berlin venedig die wir die rote
karte in die urne werfen wollen den soli
hier und jetzt abschaffen
die die blaue zocken wollen das noch
nicht so ganz der finanzminister
begründete das so
gutverdiener sollen so lief weiterhin
zahlen das sei gerecht außerdem nötig
wegen der deutschen einheit
weil da noch was zu tun ist ist es auch
richtig dass die über hohe und sehr
verfügen weiterhin den
solidaritätszuschlag errichten es ist
aus meiner sicht das richtige zeichen
für das zusammenwachsen in deutschland
eingeführt wurde der soli 1991 im
schwarz-gelben kabinett von helmut kohl
für den aufschwung ost hiess es damals
verwendet wurde er aber auch für andere
zwecke aus geplanten zwei jahren wurden
jahrzehnte damals gesagt wir müssen ihn
abschaffen wenn seinen grund entfällt
der grund entfällt zum 31 12 2009 10
dieses versprechen muss die politik
jetzt einlösen das ist eine
glaubwürdigkeit frage ich möchte jeden
bürger der über das jahr 2019 hinaus den
solidaritätszuschlag zahlen muss
ermuntern hiergegen zu klagen grüne und
linke werfen der koalition soziale
ungerechtigkeit vor
profitieren würden von der entscheidung
kinderlose und besserverdienende
fast die hälfte der bevölkerung jeder
zweite bundesbürger hat von der
abschaffung des solis nichts weil die
nämlich zu wenig verdienen um den soli
zu bezahlen
die bundesregierung wird sich auf klagen
einstellen müssen
fdp und wirtschaft haben schon den gang
vor die gerichte angekündigt deutschland
ist einer drohenden rezession vorerst
entgangen nach zuletzt einem minus legte
das wachstum im dritten quartal
überraschend leicht zu das teilte das
statistische bundesamt mit grund für das
plus ist vor allem die kauflaune der
konsumenten zwischen juli und september
wuchs das bruttoinlandsprodukt um 0,1
prozent im vergleich zum vorquartal
impfen gegen masern manche eltern
möchten dass ihren kindern ersparen oder
sie vergessen es schlicht seit jahren so
viele dass die impfquote nicht erreicht
wird jetzt hat der bundestag entschieden
impfung gegen masern wird pflicht denn
forscher sagen
ab einer quote von 95 prozent bei der
entscheidenden zweiten impfung ist die
krankheit bundesweit im griff derzeit
sind aber nur 93 prozent geimpft zwei
prozentpunkte unterschied das klingt
nach wenig und bedeutet doch
es würde hunderte ansteckungen vermeiden
und vier bis sieben todesfälle pro jahr
petra otto ob er mag oder nicht dieser
peaks ist pflicht ab märz 2020 müssen
alle kita und grundschulkinder zweimal
gegen masern geimpft sein
genauso die beschäftigten dort
nachzuweisen durch den impfausweis der
gesundheitsminister greift durch will
die masern ausrotten keine toleranz für
impfgegner wenn ich im übrigen einige
höhere die sagen ist hätte den kindern
ganz gut mal eine solche erkrankung
durch zu machen dann ist das auch eine
form von körperverletzung weil jeder
unnötige infektion vor allem mit einer
krankheit die auch so bösartig verlaufen
kann ist eben eine gefährdung von leib
und leben
wer das anders sieht dem drohen strafen
bis 2500 euro bußgeld für eltern die
ihre kinder nicht impfen lassen
für ungeimpfte des personal und für
kitas die ungeimpfte kinder aufnehmen
außerdem kann diesen die aufnahme in die
kita verweigert werden zur schule müssen
sie trotzdem
es gilt die schulpflicht nur die afg hat
heute nein gesagt zu diesem vorhaben
setzt auf aufklärung aber nicht auf
licht das geht der mündige bürger mit
seinen bürgerrechten das ist mehr als
500 masern fälle gab es bisher in diesem
jahr in deutschland
leonies mutter war anfang selbst
skeptisch doch ihr arzt hat sie
überzeugt wir haben uns entschieden ihn
impfen zu lassen weil wir einfach denken
dass wir eine soziale verantwortung
mittragen gerade gegenüber den kindern
zweitling die noch nicht impft werden
können denn die kleinen und die
schwachen haben nur dann schutz wenn sie
es gar nicht angesteckt werden können
der autobauer daimler will in den
kommenden drei jahren massiv sparen
allein eine milliarde euro beim personal
jede jeder zehnte führungsposten soll
gestrichen werden
das teilte vorstandschef ola källenius
auf einer investorenkonferenz in london
mit der konzern brauche geld für die
e-mobilität außerdem verursachten die
co2 vorgaben der eu
hohe kosten die türkei macht ihre
ankündigung wahr sie schiebt
ausländische islamisten und es an enger
in ihre heimat ab in berlin landeten
heute die ersten eine siebenköpfige
familie strenggläubige salafisten aus
niedersachsen
offen ist ob sie je etwas mit dem es zu
tun hatten in syrien waren sie
jedenfalls nicht und die große frage ist
wie umgehen mit diesen kindern und
erwachsenen die möglicherweise
gefährlich sind
ralph goldmann und thomas münten heute
nachmittag startete die siebenköpfige
familie aus der türkei zurück nach
deutschland
morgen dann werden zwei kinderlose
frauen wieder heimkehren gegen diese
frauen die bisherigen erkenntnissen
zufolge im netz aktiv waren ermitteln
die behörden im einzelfall schauen wir
es uns an gibt es strafrechtlich
relevante vorwürfe
das hat dann die justiz zu beurteilen
und sofern das nicht der fall ist prüfen
wir ob es eine gefährdung über hand gibt
und dann spricht treffen wir
entsprechende maßnahmen nach dem
gefahrenabwehr gesetzt nach aktuellen
erkenntnissen des
bundesinnenministeriums befinden sich 95
deutsche aus dem kampfgebiet noch in
haft dazu kommen rund 160 bis 170 kinder
wichtigste aufgabe für die behörden dass
bei den frauen und kindern die so
genannte die radikalisierung der weg
zurück in die deutsche gesellschaft der
pädagoge thomas mücke arbeitet schon
seit langem mit rückkehrern seine
erfahrungen
wir müssen mit der familie zusammen
arbeiten schauen auch aus dem familiären
system ganz unterstützen kann wir müssen
schauen dass die person wieder
eigenständig denken und nicht
menschenverachtenden einstellungen
hinterherlaufen wir müssen schauen dass
sie sozial integriert werden vorher ist
nicht abgeschoben werden die kämpfer
selbst die agilität vernünftig meint der
vorsitzende des parlamentarischen
kontrollgremiums sowieso moment läuft
türkei bietet an
wir erklären den einzelfall übernehmen
denjenigen so haben unsere behörden eine
chance das ganze auch sehr routiniert
und gut vorbereitet
dann durchzuführen wenn die rückführung
der deutschen elf kämpfer beginnt ist
noch offen
der türkische präsident erdogan war
gerade im weißen haus in washington zu
besuch und wurde von seinem amtskollegen
schon überschwänglich empfangen
ich bin ein großer fan des präsidenten
so donald trump dabei hatte er noch vor
einem monat gedroht die türkei
wirtschaftlich zu vernichten
wegen ihres international umstrittenen
einmarsches in nordsyrien dem kampf
allerdings erst möglich gemacht hatte
die leidtragenden dieser politik sind
auch tausende kurden die vor der
türkischen armee flüchten aus dem
türkisch syrischen grenzgebiet in den
nordirak
dort hat unsere reporterin katrin
eigendorf familien getroffen die in
lagern untergekommen sind in babylon und
im benachbarten barras beide bereits
jetzt überfüllt
3 tage wach mit nano unterwegs auf der
flucht mit seiner frau und fünf kleinen
kindern von der türkisch syrischen
grenze in den nordirak im
flüchtlingslager gavilan haben sie die
mehr als 7000 meist kurdische familien
schutz gefunden
niemand will zurückkehren sie haben alle
angst vor weiteren angriffen der
türkischen armee
es interessiert sie nicht ob es frauen
kinder oder alte menschen sind sie töten
jeden ich werde nicht nach syrien
zurückkehren wir hoffen dass wir hilfe
bekommen damit wir mit den kindern in
ein haus ziehen können
unterstützung vom
arbeiter-samariter-bund familien mit
kleinen kindern erhalten umgerechnet 40
euro pro kind für warme winterkleidung
eine ähnliche situation im
flüchtlingslager bader rasch wo mehr als
12.000 menschen schutz gefunden haben
die meisten sind kinder
sie haben ihr leben hinter sich gelassen
sie kommen hier hin und brauchen alles
un hcr und partner stellen die komplette
unterstützung die wir ihnen geben können
innerhalb kurzer zeit hat die kurdische
regionalregierung sich darauf
eingestellt die flüchtlinge aus dem
norden
uns aufzunehmen doch aus der notlage
könnte jetzt ein dauerzustand werden
in den flüchtlingslagern im norden des
irak richten sie sich auf einen langen
winter ein
denn niemand hier rechnet damit so bald
in die heimat in norden syriens
zurückkehren zu können so unsicher zu
instabil ist die lage dort nur wenige
flüchtlinge verlassen in diesen tagen
war rasch was sind die familien die
verwandte im irak haben die sie
aufnehmen können
es wird eng auf der welt die bevölkerung
wächst rasant jeden tag kommen etwa
230.000 menschen dazu eine uno-konferenz
in nairobi hat strategien gesucht um den
anstieg abzubremsen
aktuell leben rund 7,7 milliarden
menschen auf der erde doch schon 2050
dürften es fast zehn milliarden sein
danach flachte die kurve ab dennoch
erwarten die experten erst um die
jahrhundertwende ein ende des wachstums
besonders rasant wächst nach wie vor
afrika dem krueger carolina chiang aus
dem slum kibera in nairobi bekam ihr
erstes baby mit 13 jahren dann erst
begann sie zu verhüten
als sie später heiratete aber bekamen
sie und ihr mann noch einmal sechs
kinder bis er sie sitzen dies nur mühsam
hält sie sich und die kinder heute über
wasser es fehlt fast an alle inder kamal
essen haben essen wir wir haben uns aber
auch daran gewöhnt dass mahlzeiten
ausfallen dann trinken wir morgens einen
starken tee verzichten auf das
mittagsessen so ist unser leben frauen
wie carolina chen sollen gestärkt werden
durch mehr informationen und zugang zu
verhütungsmitteln durch bessere bildung
und perspektiven das ist das ziel der
weltbevölkerung konferenz die heute in
der ruby zu ende geht
wenn man investiert um den
lebensstandard der eigenen familie zu
verbessern macht es keinen sinn viele
kinder zu haben die geburten abstände
müssen größer sein damit weniger kinder
geboren werden
die man sich dann kümmern kann 264
milliarden dollar sind notwendig um
diese ziele in den kommenden zehn jahren
zu erreichen sagt der
un-bevölkerungsfonds es geht auch darum
die bislang erreichten erfolge nicht zu
gefährden
in kenia etwa benutzen heute knapp die
hälfte der frauen moderne
verhütungsmittel
wir waren als kinder zu acht aber ich
möchte nicht so viele wie meine mutter
denn es gibt große herausforderungen
heute es kostet viel geld viele kinder
großzuziehen und später gibt es kommt
jobmöglichkeiten länder und
organisationen haben sich den zielen
verpflichten und sind sie nicht in
vielen bewertungsportalen im internet
geben nutzer auskunft über ihre
erfahrungen zum beispiel was hotels oder
reisen angeht allerdings sind nicht alle
dieser bewertungen echt das
urlaubsportal holidaycheck hat gegen
eine firma geklagt die erfundene
bewertungen an hotels verkauft
und sie hat recht bekommen vor dem
münchner landgericht das urteil die fake
bewertungen der firma sind rechtswidrig
und müssen gelöscht werden
berlin soll ein neues museum bekommen
für moderne kunst eine scheune wie
spötter den entwurf nennen
die wird allerdings mindestens doppelt
so teuer wie geplant der
haushaltsausschuss im bundestag hat
heute mehr als 350 millionen euro für
das prestige projekt bewilligt stefanie
groß berichtet
hier soll es stehen das museum der
moderne die große brache zwischen
philharmonie und nationalgalerie mit
kunst beleben
der entwurf geliebt und verspottet nach
jahren des streites solle endlich gebaut
werden
wir sind natürlich schon willens die
kritiker zu überzeugen dass es ein
großartiges gebäude ist dass es auch in
dieser dimension notwendig ist um die
kunst entsprechend zu präsentieren
was aber auch klar ist dass die summe
die bereitgestellt wurde unser extrem
verpflichtet denn schon vor dem
spatenstich verdoppelten sich die
baukosten auf angepeilte 450 millionen
ein grund der denkmalschutz für die
anliegende matthäuskirche
es muss maler und tiefer gebaut werden
heute genehmigt der bund kosten von rund
364 millionen euro
doch nicht alle unterstützen dies einen
vorsichtigen haushälter ist die
schmerzgrenze da schon überschritten
deswegen hat sie die fdp hier auch nicht
mitgestimmt mit den anderen fraktionen
das tut schon weh aber wir müssen auch
akzeptieren dass wenn ein solcher
mehrheitsbeschluss ist dann muss eben
genau kontrolliert werden kosten und bau
sollen halbjährlich überprüft werden
staatsministerin monika grütters kämpfte
für den entwurf der star architekten aus
basel die auch die elbphilharmonie
bauten im museum des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts sollen kunstschätze die
bisher im keller lagern endlich zu sehen
sein
keine stadt und kein land haben das
zwanzigste jahrhundert so erlebt und
erlitten wie deutschland und berlin
und jetzt können wir endlich die kunst
dieses zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
angemessen präsentieren
in sieben jahren soll das vorzeige
museum seine türen öffnen ob es bei den
geplanten millionen bleiben wird die
bauherren glauben fest daran
und jetzt freuen wir uns noch mit einem
kollegen harald lesch bekommt gerade in
köln den hanns joachim friedrichs preis
zusammen mit der wdr-moderatorin
meitingen kim begründung beiden gelingt
es mit ihren sendungen und youtube
kanälen wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse
verständlich zu machen und in politische
diskussionen einzuordnen
der astrophysiker harald lesch modell
wird im zdf unter anderem
cosmos und tricks und damit nach dubai
norbert zur para wm der leicht alle tage
wieder sozusagen ist der vorletzte tag
dieser weltmeisterschaft bislang
sechsmal gold für das deutsche team
einmal silber und heute die zweite
bronzemedaille und die rote ali lassen
über 200 meter in der kategorie der
beidseitig oberschenkel amputierten ist
lass ihn links im bild nur außenseiter
dem 31 jahre alten berliner gelingt es
aber den us-amerikaner portas hinter
sich zu lassen
an der spitze der südafrikaner mango der
den briten weiter distanziert beide mit
deutlich schnelleren zeiten angereist in
persönlicher bestleistung holt sich
lassen dahinter aber die angestrebte
bronzemedaille
eine medaille mit nach hause zu nehmen
war für mich das ziel und das habe ich
jetzt mit dem dritten klasse reicht aber
ich denke so step by step geht's
aufwärts den beiden favoriten will näher
kommen bis zu den paralympics in tokio
seinem nächsten großen ziel
titelverteidiger alexander zverev hat
bei den atp finals in london den
vorzeitigen einzug ins halbfinale
verpasst
er unterlag dem griechen stefan justiz
ipass klar in zwei sätzen mit 3 6 und 2
6 12 trifft morgen auf den russen daniil
im medwedew ein sieg und der hamburger
wäre definitiv im halbfinal und
übermorgen in mönchengladbach das
vorletzte em quali spiel der deutschen
fußball nationalmannschaft einen sieg
gegen weissrussland könnte dem team von
jogi löw schon fürs weiterkommen reichen
wohlgemerkt könnte die em-qualifikation
hat sich unangenehme angefühlt dass sie
tatsächlich wahr
fünf siege aus sechs spielen wenn
deutschland am samstag gegen
weissrussland gewinnt ist die mannschaft
bei der euro dabei oder das erste spiel
ich glaube wir das gewinnen sind wir
schon qualifiziert das kann nicht ganz
genau
also meine information ist so dass wir
gewinnen dass sie dann durch sind noch
nicht ganz da muss niederlande auch
gewinnen
ja gut aber
[Musik]
oder engine ja ich glaube das werden sie
schafften die spielen daheim zur
aufklärung bei einem deutschen erfolg
darf nordirland gleichzeitig gegen die
niederlande nicht gewinnen dann sind
alle hürden auf dem weg zur em bewältigt
na dann ist ja jetzt alles klar wie
kloßbrühe
im süden deutschlands gibt es morgen
etwas regen und schnee wie es im rest
aussieht sagt gleichstand erni marietta
slomka begrüßt sie um viertel vor zehn
im heute-journal und wir wünschen ihnen
noch einen entspannten abend bis morgen
wenn sie mir lieber wieder sehen einen
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter eine recht
ungewöhnliche wetterlage haben wir
derzeit mit einem sehr umfangreichen
hoch über dem osten europas und die
tiefs müssen weit in den süden
ausweichen sehen hier das tief von den
britischen inseln runter rauschen bis in
den mittelmeerraum oder sagt ihr feuchte
luft an und das wird gegen die alpen
gedrückt so gibt es in den nächsten
tagen ergiebige schneefälle in den alpen
und sturm wieder an der adria zum
beispiel morgen und am sonntag wird das
dann der fall sein
schauen wir in die nacht bei uns ist es
eher ruhig vor allem im süden
deutschlands
hier bildet sich nebel nach norden ist
etwas mehr los mit einem strammen
ostwind und die temperaturen sinken dazu
bis auf minus drei grad an den alpen und
plus vier grad an der ostsee morgen im
tagesverlauf kommen mehr worten im süden
auf und dann schneit es in den bergen
regen setzt sich bis etwa zum einen
durch sonst ist weniger los nur der wind
der ist weiterhin stark aus östlichen
richtungen temperaturen dazu erreichen 4
grad am alpenrand und 14 grad im
südosten
die nächsten tage am samstag wird es im
nordwesten regnen sonst bleibt trocken
bei drei bis elf grad die darauf
folgenden tage sehen weiterhin
durchwachsen aus ein schöner abend